[Musique]
prêt pour en débattre nous sommes avec
est laurent courtois président de la
section bovine de la fdsea du rhône et
l'oni vieille blanchard présidente de
l'association végétarienne de france
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france adore
ce qui était au départ une mesure où le
précise quand même destinée il y est
surtout à la crise sanitaire devient
débat jugé préhistorique 1 par la
ministre de la transition écologique
barbara pompili des repas unique sans
viande
votre réaction laurent courtois écoutez
notre réaction c'est le maire de lyon a
dépassé les limites
c'est à dire que la loi de 2011 oh tu
dois mettre en évidence quatre points
sur 20 avec de la viande non achi que ça
soit steel 2 feront aux moutons dans les
repas de la cantine scolaire
donc monsieur le maire de respect ne
respectent pas la loi par dont ils ne
respectent pas la loi c'est à dire que
dit la loi pour bien nous éclairer
laurent courtois parce que peut-être que
nos téléspectateurs et d'ailleurs
moi-même ignore ce qu'il ya dans la loi
concernant en tout cas les menus de
cantine scolaire
la loi oblige de mettre quatre points
sur 20 de viande non h et en boeuf veau
et moutons sans compter la viande hachée
alors elodie vieille blanchard l'état ne
respecteraient pas la loi c'est ce que
vous avez envie de retenir de cette
polémique
alors non pas du tout en fait monsieur
courtois fait référence à un arrêté de
2011 mais entre temps la loi et galim en
fait à remplacer cet arrêté est
aujourd'hui en fait ce que dit la loi
c'est que il est obligatoire de servir
au moins une fois par semaine une
options végétariennes donc ça peut être
tous les jours de la semaine donc
il n'y a pas de problème du point de vue
de la loi pas du tout alors la question
de fond finalement parce que peut-être
je le répète à une partie nos
téléspectateurs ignorait tout simplement
qu'il y avait ce genre d'injonction dans
la loi mais de la viande
oui ou non revient à se poser peut-être
la question à ce que le législateur et a
fortiori les taxis mettre son grain de
sel dans les menus des cantines est ce
que finalement ce ne sont pas aux
parents de décider
laurent courtois je dirais c'est un peu
tout le monde
il en va de la vie de nos territoires
parce que manger que de que du végétal
importés je dirais n'est pas au niveau
carbone quelque chose de très de très
bien
c'est à dire vous dit en gros pardon
c'est interdit sur le territoire proche
de lyon que ça sur les monts du
beaujolais les mobiles donné on ne peut
rien faire d'autre que de l'élevage
donc nous avons des prairies qui capte
le carbone une en anglais dans
l'actualité
et c'est le sait la vie de l or l
olivier blanchard
pour vous c'est un discours qui est
audible de la part de notre ami
agriculteur il faut aussi tenir compte
du territoire des agriculteurs
dans ces affaires de menus de cantine on
sait quelque chose finalement à écarter
pour vous et prioriser d'autres
impératifs et je crois que déjà il faut
replacer un petit peu le contexte c'est
à dire que là on est dans un cadre de
gestion de crise avec un protocole
sanitaire renforcée des enfants qui
doivent être à une distance physique
d'au moins deux mètres donc c'est dans
ce contexte là en fait que le maire de
lyon dans un contexte où il ya toujours
eu deux menus un menu sans viande un
menu avec viande le menu sans viande
étant choisie par 50 % des usagers a
choisi d'imposer un menu unique pour
seulement cette semaine donc c'est un
contexte vraiment très spécifiques
par ailleurs c'est vrai qu'il ya toute
une démarche en fait de d'écologisation
des menus dans les cantines lyonnaises
je sais que la municipalité de lyon a
rencontré les acteurs des filières
locales y compris les acteurs de la
filière bovine
donc je pense que ce n'est pas tout à
fait approprié ici de réagir à ce sujet
là je pense que les éleveurs manifestent
une détresse mais il ya aussi une
expression un peu opportuniste par
rapport à la situation actuelle qui est
vraiment un sujet de gestion de crise
voilà il y avait deux menus ils ont
choisi le menu le plus inclusive c'est à
dire qui convient à 100 % des usagers
c'est une décision logique de bon sens
c'est une décision qui avait été prise
par monsieur collomb il ya l'année
dernière ont fait au mois de mai dans le
même contexte et qui n'avait pas du tout
susciter toutes les réactions que ça
suscite aujourd'hui
alors justement ça suscite des réactions
peut-être parce que avec ce que vous
nous avez expliqué dans votre première
partie il ya peut-être aussi une
démarche écologique là dedans on parle
de la crise sanitaire mais ce n'est
peut-être pas le fond du problème c'est
votre avis en tout cas laurent courtois
vous avez le sentiment aujourd'hui qu'on
vous joue un mauvais tour sans en
afficher clairement les contours
oui tout à fait on connaît les idées les
idéologies du maire de lyon
on comprend pas pourquoi lyon n'arrive
pas à mettre des repas avec de la viande
et que toutes les îles à 36000 communes
en france
les autres communes se débrouille très
bien mettre de la viande même en temps
de crise
pour nous c'est un faux débat l'écho
vide c'est une fois ses excuses en tout
cas oui pour nous éleveurs oui c'est une
fausse excuse alors en tout cas je
voudrais vous faire réagir sur quelques
réactions parce que ce débat a suscité
beaucoup de prises de parole entre hier
et aujourd'hui
celle notamment du député la république
en marge de l'indre françois jolivet
écouter ils n'en veulent plus il rêve
d'un monde où la viande n'existe plus il
rêve d'imposer leur idéologie
minoritaires d'extract rice de nos
valeurs communes
dans le sillage de leurs dogmes la fin
de l'élevage français
pour moi c'est non alors l audi vient
blanchard 1 ils se sont évidemment les
écologistes vous êtes président de
l'association végétarienne de france est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
diagnostic de françois jolivet en gros
on veut éliminer la viande de ce monde
et notamment pour commencer par les
menus de cantine de nos écoliers
en fait il ya un consensus international
à la fois sur les questions d'écologie
et sur les questions de santé donc en
france le haut conseil de santé publique
la mcef recommande de réduire assez
fortement la consommation de protéines
animales notamment dans les cantines il
ya aussi évidemment tous les enjeux
écologiques que ce soit des enjeux
climatiques des enjeux liés à la
biodiversité
en fait tous les scénarios aujourd'hui
de transition agricole et écologique
revendique une forte très forte
décroissance de la consommation de
protéines animales donc ça n'est pas du
tout un enjeu partisan c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est consensuelle
je pense que même les acteurs de
l'élevage avec lesquels on échange se
rendent compte qu'il ya une nécessaire
transition amorcée donc là dessus je
pense que ce serait beaucoup plus
intelligent en fait à la fois de la part
de l'état est à part des représentants
de l'élevage de réfléchir à cette
transition et de voir comment on peut
envisager une transition sur les
territoires de l'emploi pour un maintien
de la ruralité pour un maintien
justement de de l'emploi plutôt que de
s'opposer à ces transitions qui sont
inéluctables mais encore une fois je re
je crois que ça n'est même pas le sujet
ici puisque c'est vraiment un sujet
très court terme de gestion du protocole
sanitaire ça effectivement elodie
vieille blanchard c voilà ce qu'on
voudrait peut-être pas nous faire croire
parce que c'est qu'avant c'était
l'objectif officiel c'était ce lien avec
la crise sanitaire mais vous voyez bien
que le débat va au delà puisque vous le
dites vous même il ya une transition qui
va se mettre en place sauver aussi vous
proposer d'écouter eric zemmour un
polémiste chez nos confrères de ces news
mais essayiste évidemment également sur
son avis sur la question
il y a deux raisons qui poussent les
maires à faire des menus sans viande
la présence d'une population musulmane
et l'idéologie écolo vegan arrivée
d'eric zemmour en lui il n'y croit pas
du tout à ce lien avec la crise
sanitaire on est dit il dans l'idéologie
en l'occurrence écolo vegan laurent
courtois c'est aussi votre avis où il
pousse un peu trop peut-être eric
zemmour sur ce thème
on connaît eric zemmour pour ses pour
ses phrases mais j'aurais revenir au
niveau de l'agronomie mi6 ont passé tout
en végétal en france en fait déjà des on
n'aurait pas la dépendance alimentaire
et pour avoir du végétal il faut de la
matière organique animal on a on a eu
des commandes hier des je perds mes mots
excusez moi on sait que sansan matières
organiques animales le végétal pouces en
bien moindre quantité donc en france on
ne peut pas produire assez de végétale
pour nourrir tout le monde j'irai si on
arrêtait l'animal elodie vieille
blanchard votre réponse il ya beaucoup
de demandes et c'est un sujet qui est
tout à fait contestable mais je crois
que c'est même pas la question ici fin
on n'est pas en train de parler d'un
monde où il ya plus de 12 ou d'élevage
on est en train de parler d'un moment où
il ya un peu moins d'élevage en
particulier en france où on mange deux
fois plus de viande qu'à l'échelle de la
planète
on dépend beaucoup des importations de
protéine végétale pour nourrir les
animaux qu'on consomme en france il
s'agit notamment de l'importation de
soja qui vient massivement de la région
de l'ex amazonie et donc on n'est
vraiment pas dans ce sujet là donc ça me
semble tout à fait erroné de mettre en
avant ce genre de sujet alors
inconscient en tout cas du sujet
sensible du côté des agriculteurs
emmanuel macron s'est emparé également
du débat aujourd'hui à lors d'une visite
en côte d'or je vous propose d'écouter
le président
le changement ne peut se faire du jour
au lendemain nous sommes engagés
collectivement dans une très grande
transition
il faut de tout remettre des
légumineuses avoir aussi une viande de
qualité rester dans un modèle complet
d'alimentation voilà dupont pas dû
attendre son cadre de ce débat lié à la
crise sanitaire il
il s'empare du débat de fond le chef de
l'état laurent courtois ça vous rassure
d'entendre ces propos plutôt apaisant du
chef de l'état bien sûr c'est son rôle
d'apaiser les tensions mais je dirais
que quand même là la viande rouge est
importante pour un enfant de kate en
primaire on sait que le que le faire
végétale de mal assimilée par ses
enfants il faut du niger qui gaine delà
de la viande rouge en est fait alors
elodie veille blanchard voilà ce côté
apaisant il faut de tout y compris des
légumineuses en gros le chef de l'état
qui essaie de ne fâcher personne votre
réaction
mais ici on est quand même en train de
parler sur donc on est en train de
parler de quatre repas sur quatorze
pendant une période de sept semaines
donc évidemment que c'est tout à fait
possible que les enfants se passe de
viande pendant quatre repas pendant
cette semaine c'est à dire qu'on en
voiture par la position scientifique
unanimes c'est qu' il n'y a pas du tout
besoin de viande ni d'ailleurs de
poisson pour être en bonne santé
et d'ailleurs je reprends les propos du
professeur mariotti qui est le président
du comité d'experts spécialisés
nutrition de la ne cesse donc la
référence nationale sur le sujet selon
lequel les enfants végétariens ont
globalement un meilleur état
nutritionnel que les enfants omnivore
donc il ya vraiment pas de problème sur
sur le sujet je crois que le vrai
problème et on ne s'en rend bien compte
c'est que on a des filières d'élevage
qui sont en détresse qui se sentent
menacés par la montée actuelle des de la
prise de conscience sur les enjeux
écologiques sur les enjeux éthiques
mais je crois que la réponse à apporter
à ça c'est pas de la part des cantines
de soutenir des filières en crise ce
n'est pas le rôle des cantines en fait
la bonne réponse à mon sens c'est de
réfléchir à des transitions au niveau
des territoires au niveau du modèle
agricole et ça ça doit se faire
évidemment avec les filières d'élevage
mais on doit pas s'opposer en fait à des
transitions qui sont inéluctables et qui
vont dans le bon sens que ce soit pour
la santé publique pour l'écologie ou
bien évidemment pour pour l'éthique
laurent courtois votre réponse parce que
c'est vrai que ce n'est peut-être pas
aux cantines de gérer ce genre de
situation vous répondez quoi elodie
vieille blanche ah oui tout à fait c'est
pour le rôle des cantines mais bon c'est
quand même un message qu'on envoie à la
population dans le sens où la viande est
mauvaise pour le club pour la santé ce
qui n'est pas le cas mais je voudrais je
voudrais rebondir sur la mairie de lyon
qui nous a proposé en effet de prendre
contact avec nous pour l'heure le la
reprise de l'école au mois d'avril
au bout de sept semaines pour travailler
avec nous pour fournir de la viande
locale dont point on emboîte le pas en
disant qu'on n'ait pas parié très bien
le mot de la fin elodie vieille
blanchard pour vous on l'a compris vous
nous dites oui il se débat il y à la
crise sanitaire très bien mais il
faudrait aller plus loin avec plus de
menus végétariens à l'école ce serait
une bonne chose bien sûr va déjà nous on
se réjouit que ce débat émerge parce
qu'en fait on a entendu de la part des
représentants de l'état des arguments
complètement erronée
et pull et donc ça nous permet de
ramener un certain nombre de vérités sur
la santé sur l'écologie donc ça c'est
très bien
et évidemment c'est une bonne occasion
de poser aussi cette nécessaire
transition de nos modèles agricoles et
alimentaires donc on est très content de
cette de cette occasion pour merci
beaucoup à tous les deux et olivier
blanchard laurent courtois d'avoir
accepté ce débat en direct sur rt france